and now all i want is some romance
between them that's all because that's
been you know hinted at and confirmed
over time and i want to see it yeah i
want to see it too yeah man them
touching their wands together call me by
your wand
[Music]
hidey ho reject those we got ourselves a
trailer for fantastic beasts the
dumbledore story here rhymes with
grindelwald
what's this one secrets of
yes that's what it's called well leave a
like if you are here i'm sure we've set
some harry potter fans just by
butchering the title at the top let's do
it
memory is everything
without it we are blind
without it we lead the plate of our
world's chance
you know he is good casting absolutely
stretchy sorry to disturb you thomas but
i've just received troubling news tell
me what is it it's grindelwald
our time is closed my brothers and
sisters our world with the marcos the
kings
today
the world as we know it is coming undone
[Music]
if we're to defeat him
you'll have to trust me mr kowalski we
need you said it wanted out on that one
out
you do know i'm a witch right
homeboy lost somebody why should i give
you something jacob
oh look out
no match no longer just visiting us
entry
who wouldn't like our chances
oh
no one can know everything
not even you
[Music]
what you're doing is madness
with or without you i'll burn down their
world
dangerous times
favor dangerous men
if by tea time all of us are still alive
we should consider our efforts a success
mr kowalski my pleasure
hey double there's a good thing to turn
you back on the rule of requirement was
it
was you said we could reshape the world
even if we make mistakes
we can't try to make things right
[Music]
what
we're gonna need some help
[Music]
there's nothing you can do to stop me
[Music]
things are not quite what they appear
i trust you're enjoying your wand mr
kowalski
got a wand
right man
newt hooked him up can i keep this
[Music]
no match no longer
why did he get a one i mean he gives it
to him like part way through the trailer
i think when he holds it up on the train
and he looks at him across the bar
that's that's the moment he's giving up
oh man there's so much happening yeah i
know i give you something take it
oh look out
no match no longer i've been lying if i
said i wasn't dazzled that was pretty
magical i agree with you that's the
thing man like these movies and this
world they do cut very enticing very
intriguing trailers and as much as i did
not care for the crimes grindelwald this
has me very much enticing i gotta say
you know mads mikkelsen it's weird when
you'd say mads mickelson's cast is going
to wall like he's doing exactly what
you'd imagine and there's no issue with
that
like wow you are perfect for this role
you should have been here from the start
dude you just upset a lot of people by
saying that yeah i mean unfortunate
circumstances but we got a pretty great
consolation prize in beloved actor
madness nicholson there were so many of
those scenes where they're just sitting
across that i'm like i'm looking forward
so much to seeing him and jude law have
seen work together you know i'm a big
fan of the hannibal series that mads
mickelson was the title character for
and just seeing like them at the diner
was making me flash the hannibal of like
the back and forth and protagonists and
antagonists i'm i'm probably most
looking forward to that as just a film
lover but in terms of like reinstilling
excitement and hope for the fantastic
beasts franchise this feels the most
harry potter-esque as compared to the
other two harry potter films which take
that what you will like some people
might think that's a good thing to film
i think that's a bad thing i personally
found that to be pretty magical to have
this feel like a true like dumbledore
prequel is really exciting and what was
the name of the of of what ezra miller
when he's a dumbledore really it's not a
aurelius i think it is dumbledore we
gotta uncover what that is i know that
created a whole can of worms for people
like wait a minute what is how is he the
bro i thought we had this establishment
at the time
why'd they forget about the third
brother yet it's like a fast and furious
you know john cena dominic toretto thing
that's what i have going on over here
this just feels like it has the real
spirit behind it i think newt scamander
has been pushing more to the background
than ever in fact this is more like a
jacob kowalski movie than it did in its
it absolutely did not do anything to
alleviate that aspect and i like newt
and i like what eddie redmayne does in
that character i'm happy that the
character is still here but even as of
this trailer every time they cut to him
i was like oh yeah i guess he will be in
this movie and oh yeah i guess there
will be some fantastic beasts and oh
yeah i guess they'll find a way to make
that work i don't exactly understand why
everyone's like new tweety to you
specifically yeah i mean absolutely the
world they can always get me back to
harry potter with the world and yes
seeing you know the the sprawling nature
of you have hogwarts here you have you
know america as well because that was
the charm of fantastic beasts going to
america seeing the wizarding world there
and yeah i mean you don't have queenie
you don't have catherine waterstone tina
there you go part of me thinks that
where are they yeah where the hell are
they i don't know because i mean queenie
went off and joined grindelwald in the
last one spoilers and uh you did see
queenie at one point didn't you watch a
blonde hair it's like a super brief
flash
like a blonde hair queenie but part of
me feels like i'm setting out to prove
you wrong that we saw clean you right
now do it this i don't know makes me
hopeful that perhaps they have taken
maybe some of the notes and complaints
that crimes of grindelwald had levied
towards it about being way too bloated
and way too many characters and way too
much like a novel it looks like this
could be a well-proportioned adventure
for a movie and maybe could take the
best elements of the previous film and
build on them here while also bringing
us back to some of that nostalgic
hogwarts harry potter classic you know
setting and fox vibe and all that fox
the phoenix is in here absolutely i'm
sure fox is gonna be an even bigger more
prominent character being that he's a
fantastic beast and you can always find
him with dumbledore can't find him can't
find him see so queenie who knows maybe
she's dying
not found her she's at the very end of
the trailer
stupid you're a better harry potter fan
than i am all right but hey i'll say
this as as far as mining the the
trenches of harry potter for more
content i feel like diving into the
backstory of dumbledore and his
relationship to grindelwald is actually
a pretty conscientious idea and now all
i want is some romance between them
that's all because that's been you know
hinted at and confirmed over time and i
want to see it yeah i want to see it too
yeah man them touching their wands
together call me by your wand
i i think what i really desire most from
this movie more than anything is to see
a real personal tale for dumbledore
something that feels of great
consequence you know it's like we know
who's gonna win in
so yeah if we're gonna do that let's
just at least see what devastating
effects and total sacrifices it is that
you know dumbledore ultimately has to
make in this movie that's mainly it all
right guys well are you excited for
fantastic beasts 3 the dumbledore movie
leave your thoughts down below we'll
catch you guys soon